so from reading your bio you have a
Great backstory which I just wanted to
check in with I know you probably said
it like 50 million times but it's really
fascinating so here goes I understand
you you say you were broke working as a
waiter in New York yes in New York and
Ohio Oh dual waiter ship yeah well it
started in Ohio and then I moved to New
York okay guys all right
so waiting tables and I know that's you
can have a great night and you can have
a horrible night
so someone commented one day when you
went in oh there goes Obama and it was
what another co-worker another coworker
I came into work one day and this girl
goes up here comes Obama and everyone
started laughing and I laughed it was
only she only said cuz I was the only
black guy that worked there so but
everyone laughed and I laughed but then
I had an epiphany and I was like you
know what like I could come up with an
impression of this guy at the time he
was still running for office he hadn't
become president yet
and I just had an epiphany like what if
I get in to do an impression of this guy
before anyone else does it before he's
famous because if he becomes president
he'll be the most popular guy on the
planet and that would be a lot of steam
for my acting career right and this was
what year that you were 2008 2008 so
you'd already launched a YouTube yeah I
launched my youtube channel in 2005 5 ok
and how much time were you putting into
the channel 2005 because those are in
the easy days it seems like it's a
little bit a little easier than easier
yeah yeah how much time I was doing it a
lot like basically all of my free time I
was working on my youtube channel oh
okay so you come back were you tired
sometimes from these shifts and was like
oh but then you like put in time yeah
because that was like my escape that was
like my dream so it's like am I in my
head doing these silly YouTube videos
back in 2008 7 6
that was an escape for me and in my head
I felt like I was a big director you
know I get to do these silly sketches
and and and and and you know
skits and whatnot and it was my escape
at the time you know and what were
people's comments to you about this this
YouTube things most people what most
people were supportive you know most
people liked it online you can almost
anyone can find an audience and so
online I had begun to find mine and so
people were watching and most people
were
supportive and you know about it right
so then you do this Obama video and it
seems like your life pretty much changes
from that point right um do you remember
the day that you launched it and like
what happened were you at work when view
started coming in yeah I mean I had
already begun to get a lot of use in my
own but then the when I put up my first
Obama video after that girl made that
comment at work you know I came home and
I took a napkin that I had left over my
apron and I started just writing down
ideas and so I wrote down a whole script
and then I sat in from the camera and
performed it and I was really nervous
cuz I hadn't done impressions before
then and I thought people gotta think it
was stupid and I put it up and then just
like tens of thousands of you started
coming in and I was like oh they like
this hey you know so then from there was
just I just started doing more and it
just took off
so did you promote it in any way or
because you know I was Twitter even
around them I don't even know I'm pretty
sure it was but I don't think I was it's
not like I had a following on Twitter or
Instagram I don't think Instagram was
around back then it just did what it did
on its own I already built like a
network you know followers on on YouTube
so Wow
so then how soon from that day that you
launched it did you actually say did you
give you two weeks or maybe you didn't
and you said no it's no I didn't give my
two weeks right away
but around that time YouTube it had
launched a or a little bit before that
time YouTube had launched a an ad
revenue share program where content
creators could make money from posting
videos and I had gotten accepted into
that so I was slowly beginning to make a
little little side change you know not
much at all but then what happened
around the Atlanta on on the own
Election Day when he won I posted a
parody of a TI song and it just blew up
and that was the moment from there that
I was actually able to get out of a job
because of ad revenue share income and
also branded opportunities and outside
opportunities you know like hosting for
Entertainment Tonight and things like
that it just things that crazy really
fast do you remember the exact timeframe
a month two months that times meant of
work from the time that you actually
made that video that first video to
where you were out of that nine-to-five
it was about a month that I was then I
went from broke and unemployed at the
time because I wasn't even waiting
tables by that point I gotten fired from
my last waiting job and moved out here
from New York to here and so King here
was an employee
it was unemployment I started making
videos and I was just I promised myself
I wasn't gonna go back to waiting tables
again and I had just taken an interview
at a restaurant and had gotten hired and
was about to take the job and then that
video blew up and all this money
suddenly came rushing in and then I
never went back to waiting tables after
that when you were fired was it a
blessing or was it it was a blessing
because it needs to happen and it just
you know it freed me up to do other
things you know so yeah it sounds like
perfect timing gave me have you had a
day job since that first Obama video I
have not worked in nine-to-five since
2009 8 sorry did you ever envision that
being the case no you went to a
performing arts school and I know all
actors and performers what ever hope for
that but we also know that the chances
are sometimes not in our favor even for
the most talented so did you when that
happened when you were able to kind of
cross over how surreal or whatever for
you was it like um you have to pinch
yourself did you feel unworthy for a
little bit did you feel excited well no
I didn't feel unworthy because I don't
feel like I've gotten to that level of
success where I'm just like wow you know
it's it's been I've expected to be to
have successes you know like is what I
dream of and like that's what I want so
it's been it's been great and it's been
cool it's been an honor it's been a
blessing but I never really celebrate
cuz I don't feel like I'm at where I
want to be and and I I think I've done
some great things and had some great
accomplishments but I never really
celebrate too much because I there's so
much further that I want to go you know
does that make sense
do you think back to that day what if
that girl hadn't have been there and
said yeah I mean do you think back to
what if I had not only that but what if
I hadn't have done anything with that
Obama idea yeah where would I be right
now oh of course
and like it's it's a it's a massively
humbling thought just like what if that
just never happened where would I be
when I still be back in New York waiting
tables would I be miserable would I even
be acting still you know it's a it's a
you know and even that girl who made
that comment like I'm like we're friends
on Facebook and I've reached out like I
wonder each other and be like you know
thank you know yeah and I reset her once
it's like hey you know and I tried to
talk like say something but she never
even worse mind and then I don't know
she remembers who I was you know but I
wanted to say your thanks you know cuz a
lot spun out of that comment so yeah
it's it's interesting what do you think
of people that move here because you did
move here you were waiting for maybe to
find another job and they wait to be
picked it sounds like you don't wait to
be picked for things you just do them ya
know people who move out here have to
really have a lot of zeal in their heart
in their spirit they have to really go
for it you can't come out here and just
kind of like do the run of the mill or
the run of the mill auditions and just
headshots and that you have to really
find avenues to like it's like driving
in traffic you got to find a way to
swerve and moving it out and dip and
switch lanes and get ahead of people you
really have to work hard you can't wait
to be picked you cannot you have to do
it yourself when I got along the
roadside when that came across to me I
didn't want to just do a Taylor a filmed
audition and just read the script I
wanted to shoot my audition that way and
then also film it like an actual scene
in the movie so they can picture me in
the role you know I just wanted to take
a step further so you really have to
hustle you play Barney I play Barney and
Barney's going through some stuff yeah
Barney is a little bit on the run you
know he kind of considers himself a
sailor who's left one shore but hasn't
yet reached the next so he's still kind
of floating and drifting and he's got a
lot on his mind you know
because of some things that's going on
with him and his girlfriend and that
takes him pretty far or pushes him
pretty far I should say you know and to
his drift you know for someone that went
to performing arts school like you did
and is hoping to come out here or to New
York and and go on that whole like
audition treadmill I see it in people
and I know that some days they're elated
when I see them and other days they seem
pretty down so what would you say to
those people like you said that you
wouldn't advise someone to just stick to
that audition route if they want to say
well I don't have a camera or I don't
know how to edit with Adobe or Final Cut
Pro you know I don't have anybody to
shoot a webseries with like what's your
because I hear that a lot or when I
become famous I'm gonna have people
upload my stuff to YouTube but not right
now what do you say to those people that
want someone to do it for them and just
want to do that normal route that a lot
of us have learned that's the way you do
yeah it's there's nothing wrong with
traditional route of auditioning i
edition you know I love auditioning and
I want to get further into that circuit
and you know cuz auditioning is a route
that I haven't needed to use yet but
it's something now that I'm seeking
after because I want to do traditional
Hollywood work however building your own
audience can help get you into a lot of
rooms though I've gotten a lot of
auditions just because people see me
online and so what I would say to those
people who don't say you don't have a
camera you don't add it that's fine but
you can still at least you have a phone
you know you can take pictures and you
know upload the Instagram upload the
Facebook or snapchat or just anything to
help build your presence online so then
when I see you you know what about the
people that are afraid of being too
maybe they're afraid that they're going
to look too boastful to people and they
don't want to be the ones promoting
themselves they want someone to promote
them it's I mean that to me sounds kind
of self-defeating you're mean if you're
gonna be in an entertainment business
you have to promote just entertainment
so that's like it comes in the package
you're an entertainment you have to
promote yourself you have to not only
audition when you're in the room but
you have to kind of audition at all
times it's like for instance a friend of
mine is a fighter and you know someone
suggested that he should never drink
because he's trying to get a new fight
and he could get a call at any moment so
at any moment someone can come calling
for me and if I'm not on top of my game
and like promoting myself and like
working on my craft and just putting
myself out there all times you know you
never know you might miss opportunity so
a man once told me always just be ready
always be ready always be ready because
you never know when it calls him coming
you never know when an audition is going
to come in so part of that package is
always promoting yourself always being
on you know and just being ready for
that call to come in do you have time to
hang out with friends or are you doing
more yes I do yeah I have time to hang
out friends oh okay always make time for
leisure sure little R&R I do but the
more that I focus though it is it does
get harder because it's like I push
myself to focus more because I like to
go out and and party with my friends but
you have to you gotta stay focus and the
more focused I am the harder I work the
less time I have to hang out you know I
have to say no to parties sometimes
because you know there's more important
things to do do you see other people
getting caught up in that where they
want to I mean we all want to have a
circle of friends around us but yeah
it's inspiring
I do see other people get caught up in
that and it's inspiring because I have
friends who are on TV and that's where I
want to be and you know when they have
lines to read or they have a rehearsal
the next day if they have a shoulder for
the next day they don't go out you know
and I barely see them and then every
time I do see them they're like I got to
go home and study lines and while some
who might think that's boring for me
that's inspiring because it's like the
proofs in the pudding
they're at home working but they're also
in a TV show so who cares about free
time or who cares about going out when
you could be on a show and be studying
lines and living a dream so you started
on YouTube 2005 you've now transitioned
to vine how many followers do you have
on vine on vine over 3 million over 3
million okay where did the idea to jump
to vine go and how does the YouTube
videos or how do the YouTube videos and
the vine videos coincide or are they two
separate things I jump to vine because
being in social media again promoting
yourself I'm always ready to latch on to
something new in social media when it
works a lot of apps come and go and like
it's not a you know don't take them
seriously but if something works I will
get on that app because that's another
avenue to promote myself so that's why I
did it
do the to coincide not really there's
separate beasts and in a way they're
apples and oranges vine a six second
video YouTube is longer format so
they're they're pretty separate I know
with YouTube in the past you had to be
accepted to the partner program but now
anybody can monetize non copyrighted
stuff
how does vine work can you monetize the
video you can't monetize the video but
there's a lot of branding deals and
branding opportunities so people are
actually getting paid for six seconds of
work yeah where do you is there like a
site where it's like most like a
Craigslist for Viners where you can
offer your no there's no site but you
know brands come reaching out to miners
and then that's usually how that works
so first be on vine make the videos and
the audience and then brands you know if
you're good and if you fit their brand
they come call it can someone let's say
that has maybe a thousand followers on
vine get a deal of some kind of dealer
or would it have to be much higher
typically they would be looking at
someone who's like either hundreds of
thousands or over a million typically
okay we got a little work to do I think
I want to go back to YouTube for a
moment what are some of the biggest
mistakes you see people make on YouTube
whether they're a vlogger whether they
want to do you know talking head style
documentaries whatever what are some of
the biggest mistakes you see other
youtubers make mistakes that's the other
youtubers make
I would say one of the mistakes I see
other youtubers make is not being
themselves you know
people try to copy or be like someone
else or aspired to be like someone else
that they admire when the best thing you
can do is just be yourself because no
one can do you like you can do so if you
try to be someone else you're not gonna
be better at them at that because that's
what they do especially if they're
already big big for that thing some
people try to replicate what they see
and like it's like when people for many
years other websites are trying to be
the new YouTube you can't be a new
YouTube's already it's it's it's it's
it's a done deal
you can't be another YouTube you can't
be a new Michael Jackson so just be
yourself so you see people maybe being
too forced in a character type yes I
definitely see people trying to be too
forced or trying too hard when it's just
like what you just just do what you want
to do well so speaking of film so along
the roadside it's just now coming out is
that right yes okay coming now March
17th March say oh well okay st.
Patrick's Day which is a March Madness
great oh okay that's where my mind went
was st. Patty's Day so who gave you the
script how did you see it or did were
you called
um a friend of mine by the name of Danny
Danny grow that he's in the film he
plays MIT's the cop and I saw him at a
party for it was an event and he's like
I'm in this movie you should be in this
movie too I think they're casting for
roles you should check it out and so he
connected me with the directors Oren and
then Zorn sent me the script and I read
the whole thing that night and I loved
it and I said to the director I said
listen I don't know who's playing the
lead and you probably have already cast
somebody but I need to play this guy and
he was like all right well read for it
and at the time they did have someone in
mind for the lead they hadn't I don't
think they had officially casted him yet
but sent him audition tape and shortly
after that day I got a call and were
like - you got the wrong and I was like
yes
so yeah was this your first lead and
Dramat
film yes what yeah definitely my first
my first film firstly did you feel you
had to fight for the audition or you
just had to prove that you were ready
and well when you know when you find out
that they're already considering someone
for their lead role and they've pretty
much kind of already casted yeah it's a
fight you know but you know I'd like
challenges like yeah so but you weren't
into sports
no but you other than fighting fighting
oh like MMA or like martial arts yes
okay when I was I was in martial art and
I was really young so Oh
and now MMA is like that's the only
sport I watch so okay but I don't watch
like football baseball basketball no how
interesting what is it about that
challenge that - I don't know I mean
because some people cower to challenge
like that I don't know I'm probably not
explaining it right but what is it where
you just it seems like you come alive
when there's like stakes on the line a
little bit yeah I mean I just think
that's the mark of driven people like we
like challenges the feeling of
accomplishment and filling them for
becoming something so yeah yeah nice do
are you ever satisfied because that's
another mark of accomplished people
they're never you said earlier they
always know I'm not ever satisfied I'm
not and that's not a bad thing it's just
I just always want more where some
people and friends and family pat me on
the back like oh that's so amazing and I
had a but I can do it I could be doing
way more you know so what are your five
best tips for someone to gain a million
followers on vine I don't have any tips
for gaining a million followers I can
tell you what some good habits are to
grow but I wouldn't be able to directly
give advice like oh here's how to get
millions but be yourself be creative
like just just be yourself because what
might seem weird to you someone will
laugh at like there's someone who I
follow on by and they have almost no
followers but I find that person funny
because they're just themselves and
they're unique and it's just awkward and
I just find it funny so be yourself
because you never know who that will
attract be consistent
post often or frequently if you can so
that what people get used to checking
back collab with people that are bigger
than you so that way you can get new
followers let's say that's three let's
do I have two more I would say that's
the top three yes yeah what did the
performing arts school teach you about
acting that still stays with you today
that's not just about technique but
that's about the business of it um my
first acting teacher I never forget her
name was Helen Harris and she always got
on me about getting into the characters
they used to be very shy so I'd get on
stage and I'd read the lines and I just
was kind of off and then you know and
she stopped and she was with teachers
that would just yell at you oh she was
like what are you doing and I remember
that whatever script it was I was
playing someone in the army and I was
coming home and seeing my wife for the
first time in a long time she was like
you're in the army stand up straight
speak loud we direct be firm get into
like she would just go and go in on me
and so she's stuck with me because it's
like that's part of the reason now if I
get a role I like to try to attack it
you know like get into the character I'm
not the same shy kid I was back then so
now I take that with me and really dive
into a role what changed the shyness age
maturity life changed the shyness okay
so your advice for a shy actor advice
for shy actor get into some classes and
getting used to performing in front of
and with people and get training then
open you up what if someone has a social
phobia the same thing you have a social
phobia get into classes get some
training and that a good teacher and
also the people around you help you open
up talk about being driven which is
awesome and I see that and I also see
that not being satisfied which is great
I've seen a lot of driven people talk
about that which
gets them higher but is there pressure
that you place on yourself not just with
the the YouTube following and the vine
following but also because you want to
do more films like along the roadside
and and TV and things like that
is there a pressure you feel from
yourself to do what to what to keep
getting more roles to keep because it's
an engine that you've got it well yeah I
mean there's there's there's always
there's always pressure because a it's
like people don't know what it's like to
try to juggle a vine account and a
youtube account which is already
extremely time to time consuming then
thinking about how to keep growing your
Instagram because you have to post
certain times a day and pull certain
things to get more followers and then on
top of that oh wait I have this audition
and the reliance for but wait I have to
shoot a vine after shooting YouTube
video oh wait but I have more auditions
so it it is very taxing you know it
takes a lot out of you and it is there's
a level of pressure and then it's like
you know as an actor you know you're not
getting younger so you want to get more
roles faster and it's like yeah there's
a lot of pressure and then how do you
deal with it how do you compartmentalize
it it's always a work in progress trying
to come part mentalize it you know it's
it's I don't have it down I don't have a
perfect but I just continue to build my
social networks online and continue to
hit auditions when my managers or my
agent sends me auditions I go into beast
mode and I'm focused and I go in there
and I know my lines I go early and I'm
just ready to perform and I have a great
time auditioning but you know I take a
day by day trying to juggle this because
it's like it's the the internet YouTube
and vine it's still kind of like the
Wild West you know it's still under fun
even though you teach been around for a
while vines newer vine is like the Wild
West right now and like social media is
getting into the the traditional
Hollywood world it's everything is all
mixing up and everything is still new so
I'm still even at this point I'm still
learning do you ever have days where
you're not in in beast mode well of
course of course it's it's hardest
because the difference is when you're
when you're a person like me who's big
on social media you don't work a
nine-to-five it's all on you to push
yourself there's no boss and you need to
be at work at 8 a.m. unless I have a
call time that's different but on a day
to day when I'm trying to juggle YouTube
vine and Instagram and auditions and
it's just
me it takes a lot of drive to get
yourself up every day and follow our
routine without having someone push you
so that's a big challenge sometimes
especially when you you know if you live
in comfortably you don't need to get up
it can be a little bit of a challenge so
unless you have interviews